I love this chapter chapter nine
the incredible nothing
so since you love it so much I'll let
you start what do you want how do you
want to start this video so one of the
most
easy ways to look at this is that the
character the label the name
[Music]
it is overly focused on
everything that has form everything that
has shape everything that you can like
touch and feel and
because of that it is not concerned with
who the subject is
so so I'm going to focus on the
differences
this is what has been called the ten
thousand things I'm gonna focus on the
ten thousand things
and I'm not going to focus on the one
behind everything right which is
interesting right and so because the one
behind everything AKA I
it's not a thing and that's what no
thing is yes it's not a thing it's no
thing it's nothing yes I isn't a thing
yes I is some crazy formless mystery
called Consciousness or God or whatever
you want to say
I love it man you killed that that now
we have the answer to what is I
that's it it's not a thing it's this
would you say crazy formless
Cosmic you know mystery like and but the
greatest thing about it is that I feel
it yeah
I don't have to think about it if I try
to think about it I don't even know what
where my mind would go but I feel it and
that is enough I feel that I am I I feel
that I'm this formless mystery
interpreting reality gaining experiences
applying it to my shell living life
feeling the roller coaster eating the
steak
but but I itself
I don't even know if you can describe it
maybe that's what they talk about when
you say the only way to describe it is a
negation to talk about what it's not yes
yeah
it's so good but you know what is I like
you said it's like many things we can
say it is but definitely nothing would
be one of the best things because it's
the word nothing to me means nothing
there's nothing yeah there's nothing
that can describe it yes
the Dao that can be named is not the
Eternal Dao
so whatever word you use to try and
describe it isn't going to be fully it
it's going to limit it in some way and
it's Limitless right and you know box it
in somehow yeah and I also love what
you're saying earlier the negation being
one of the best ways to talk about it
what are you quote negating besides the
label
um the biggest thing for you to negate
is your Association
with the label yeah so if you can what
I've been calling like if you can just
put a freaking crowbar a little bit of a
crowbar a little room into the tightness
of your association with your label and
if you can just wiggle it a little bit
wiggle wiggle relax relax
and as you do that kind of like the
Chinese finger trap the Chinese finger
trap as you relax you can actually
investigate more and more and more yeah
that's where realization can Dawn that's
really where
these next levels can become embodied
because we're negating our
I'm obsessed on ten thousand things I'm
obsessed on differentiation I'm obsessed
with the separate costumes
and now I'm looking instead of at my
label I'm looking at what underlies
everything what's at the source
The Source yeah and is what's at the
source the same for everything
and so that and so that's I
and that's the power of negation to go
all the way
Notch Notch Notch Notch Notch Notch
Notch ah
yes
and that's how the universe knows Itself
by that formless mystery that nothing
that Consciousness that I God the
universe knows Itself by that formless
mystery yes and that formless mystery is
quote identity less and identity full so
it has absolutely no identity
but yet and yet it's full of endless
identities endless infinite identity and
no identity at the same time and to me I
just find that profound not the
realization but the ability yes
stability the ability to to to have it
be that way it's just like how again
this must be a powerful genius-like
entity that's creating such a massive
contradiction
and it works
like I'm actually my mind is being blown
as we're doing because I'm really
thinking about that likewise pretty
crazy man when you just think about it
but yeah
and this is as we share with you guys
this course what we feel is we feel a a
new level ourselves of being able to
share what
is you could say like
one of the most powerful ways to to know
yourself yeah um yeah and so we're
learning a lot through this process and
um and we're just we're really grateful
because this sort of uh like book plus
course structure plus short films this
type of like approach to it if you've
really made it this far this type of
approach to it
um it can
shift
with greater
permanence
um perfectly safe cool yeah
that's chapter nine